[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL IRISH: Hello.
Welcome to The Breakpoint,
Episode 2.
We're going to be talking
about how to be more
productive doing Web-Op
development.
And today we got some
really good stuff.
We're focusing on the Chrome
DevTools in this episode, and
specifically we're going to show
off some of the abilities
to debug your SASS
style sheets.
So with me over in London
is Addy Osmani.
And Addy's just going to get
right into it and show you
kind of how SASS debugging works
inside Chrome DevTools.
ADDY OSMANI: Awesome.
So the first thing we're going
to look at today, as Paul was
saying, are some brand new
features in the DevTools for
people that love working
with SASS.
So I'm going to go over
to my screen.
Now let's fire up
the DevTools.
OK.
So I've got a SASS project in
front of me at the moment.
Now, the first thing you
probably want to do with this
is start inspecting stuff.
So we've got a header
at the moment.
Let's inspect it.
So I've got my header in
front of me right now.
I can go and I can do
some awesome stuff.
I can like bump up
the font size.
It looks hot, it looks sexy.
And what's even better is that
I can now go and click on
style.css to see the original
file in the source view.
Now this is great, except you
can see there's some line
numbers here.
It does show me my selector, but
because I'm using SASS--
and this is actually the
compiled version of my style
sheet file--
any changes that I make in this
file are only going to be
reflected in that.
It's not going to be reflected
in the original SASS file.
And whenever I go and I try
compiling my source files,
these changes that I make to
this file are going to get
overwritten.
So what we do that's
better than this?
Now, last week we showed you
that if you go to Chrome
flags-- so let's do that very
quickly, so Chrome flags--
you can actually enable
some experiments.
So let's go to Developer
Tools.
The first thing you want to do
is Enable Developer Tools
Experiments.
Now, normally you'll have to
refresh your browser after
that, but once you do and you go
to the Settings tab, you'll
see that there's an Experiments
tab there.
Now, the option that we're
interested in is the one that
says Support for SASS.
So let's enable that.
Now, after you've enabled
Support for SAAS, you're going
to need to reload the DevTools
and refresh the page.
So we're going to do
that very quickly.
And let's open up the
DevTools once again.
Now if I go back to Elements
and we inspect our h1 once
again, what you'll see is that
we've now got access
to styles at SCSS.
And if I click into this, I can
actually edit with syntax
highlighting my original
SAAS file.
Well, this is really cool.
You've got the nesting.
You can see all of your
beautiful SASS
source, which is great.
And I can make changes
to this.
Now, before you actually make
changes, if you want them to
be visible in DevTools, you
need to go and save this.
So I'm just going to do Command
S to save this.
Alternatively, you can right
click and do Save As and save
it to the original location
that you were working in.
And now I can just go and
make changes to this.
So before I make changes, just
to let you know, so I'm
currently running LiveReload
and SASS --watch in the
background.
So it's keeping an eye
on what I'm doing.
And if I make a change--
so I've just
bumped up the font size.
Let's Command S to save that.
So what you've seen is it's
gone, and without me having to
reload the page or anything,
it's compiled my SASS file.
It's gone and it's reloaded
the page.
So I'm actually seeing the
changes in real time of what
I've done in my source file.
And that's cool.
Let's [INAUDIBLE]
that back and save it.
Now, there's a mixin.
So what I'm actually going
to do, I want to make
a change to a mixin.
So we've got a text shadow on
HTML5 PLEASE at the moment,
which is cool.
Now, let's say that I started
editing and I wanted to make
some changes.
And maybe I went and did Command
Save without knowing
that I made a mistake.
Now, normally with your CSS
editing workflow, there's no
sort of [INAUDIBLE] or error
message to tell you you've
done something wrong, that
something's been messed up.
But here, as you can see--
because I've got like
LiveReload and all my other
tools running in the
background--
I get some nice error messages
that say, OK, well, there's
some invalid CSS.
And it'll tell you exactly what
you've been doing wrong.
Now, in my case, I actually
want to replace this
completely.
So let's first dismiss this.
Now, in my case, I actually
want to go and use a mixin
that I previously defined.
So I just added my mixin and I
do a Commend S once again, and
there we go.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: That's
hot, right?
PAUL IRISH: That's
sharp, yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: So that's
really cool.
You've now gotten much better
support for SASS editing in
the DevTools, and that
will help with
your general workflow.
But on top of that, you've also
got the ability to use
all the other benefits
that the Sources
panel still gives you.
So if I went to, say, Local
Modifications--
so we were showing you a little
bit of this last week.
So if I go to Local
Modifications, I actually get
complete editing history.
So I can revert back to any
point in my editing workflow
without having to go anywhere
outside the DevTools.
And it feels so nice to
be able to do that.
So, yeah, I think that's
it for the SASS
portion of my demo.
What did you think, Paul?
PAUL IRISH: That's pretty hot.
So I think it's cool because
typically you're in a
situation where you're just
editing your SASS, and then
you compile it down, and then
you'll make a change and
you'll be like, well, somehow I
have to transport the change
I just made in the DevTools back
to the original, like the
way that I authored it.
And it's a bit awkward.
And here you can just develop
directly inside the tool and
get your immediate feedback that
you want, but you don't
have to be translating back and
forth between your SASS
and your CSS.
So that's really dope.
I dig it.
ADDY OSMANI: I like it.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
All right.
So now that we've got SASS under
control, we've got some
more things to show you.
First we're going to show you
some cool things in the Chrome
DevTools Console.
Then we're going to show you
skinning and customizing the
theme and look of the Chrome
DevTools, some deeper
inspection features inside
the DevTools, and some
goodies at the end.
But I'm going to show you some
good stuff in the Console.
Now, the first thing is, if
you've ever worked on a page
that, for instance, doesn't have
jQuery, doesn't have a
dollar function to find, and you
open up the console, and
then you type dollar, and you
start to pass in what normally
you would be saying to jQuery,
and it works or it doesn't, or
it returns an empty set, and
you're like, why is there a
dollar available inside my
console when I don't have it
on the page?--
this is the command line API.
So I'm going to show a little
bit of what's going on here.
There was a good question on
Stack Overflow a bit ago about
why there is a dollar and
double-dollar inside the DevTools.
So this actually comes
originally from Firebug.
It's the command line API.
These are all things that are
available within the context
of the Console.
So we have dollar, double
dollar, XPath, dollar-zero,
which represents the
Yeoman you have
selected, and even Inspect.
You can pass an element into
Inspect, and it'll go over to
the Elements panel, and you'll
be viewing that.
So some really cool
stuff in here.
But people have been curious
about why double-dollar is
selector and why single-dollar
has been ID.
And the funny situation is that
this is all about kind of
JavaScript history.
Double-dollar was originally
used by prototype.
And it was used as a way to grab
all the selectors, but
then jQuery was like,
you know, we'll just
throw that on dollar.
And so now there's been this
weird situation where the
legacy of double-dollar has been
what's available inside
Chrome DevTools and Firebug and
Opera Dragonfly, but at
the same time everyone's used
to grabbing selectors, not
IDs, with single-dollar.
So Addy and I met up this summer
to work on some Chrome
DevTool stuff, and we were like,
this comes up and now
and again, and we were like,
we should probably change
this, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, right.
PAUL IRISH: So we went in and
we talked to some of the
developers behind Firebug and
the Firefox DevTools, and we
talked to the Dragonfly
guys, and we're like,
let's change this?
I guess that's how it worked.
ADDY OSMANI: Pretty much.
PAUL IRISH: And so basically we
changed the definition of
dollar inside the command line
API in these developer tools.
So let's just show a little demo
of how this works now.
So I'm going to ask for--
this is the way that
it used to work.
You'd pass in an ID to dollar,
and it would grab that element
with that ID.
ADDY OSMANI: But that
just feels a little
bit awkward, right?
Because you're used to using
jQuery these days with dollar
sign, and maybe you want to be
able to stick other characters
in front of it or use
classes and all that
other stuff, right?
PAUL IRISH: Right, yeah.
So now what we did is we changed
it, but then we also
made sure that there is a kind
of like a little catch so that
you're not totally
confused when it
doesn't return anything.
So it lets you know that indeed
there is a fallback
situation here.
And so it'll recommend that you
throw in the pound, then
you get that.
So this works for everything.
I could be passing it proper
selectors, and it will always
return the first element
that matches.
It basically works like
Query selector.
So it's a breaking change.
It's a little backwards
incompatible, but we think
that it matches the common 2012
use of dollar and kind of
fits expectations a
little bit better.
So I also wanted to show some
other good stuff in here.
Another feature that was added
somewhat recently into the
Chrome DevTools Console
is dollar-underscore.
And so I believe this comes from
a Perl history, but it
essentially refers to the
previously evaluated statement.
So I'm going to go and grab
hp logo, offset width.
Cool.
And now I'm going to add
a little bit of WebKit
transition for fun, because
we're going to
do some good stuff.
And now we're going to change
the width 500 plus
dollar-underscore plus px.
And so what this is going
to do is it's going
to grab this 275--
that was the value we
had right here--
and use it in place here.
So now I evaluate this.
Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: Wow.
That is so awesome.
PAUL IRISH: Definitely against
branding guidelines, but it's
cool, it's cool.
ADDY OSMANI: You're going to
be getting a call from
marketing any minute now.
PAUL IRISH: Yup, yup.
All right.
So let's bring that back down.
Phew.
OK.
Cool.
So dollar-underscore, a small
, little convenience thing,
but I hope it comes in useful.
I know that I am commonly like
referencing things up and
down, so it should be good.
Another thing that I wanted to
show real quick is the new
object preview logging.
So let's see.
I think we have an object.
I was scouting around for
an object earlier.
Yeah.
Here we go.
So this is just some weird
object that's available on the
Google homepage.
Don't even know what it is.
But normally if you had in
your application code
something like console log, and
you did something like you
were logging out this thing,
then you would get this little
object's name, and you get the
triangle, and then you come
over here and you click it.
And that's OK, but we thought
that it would be nicer if you
got a little preview
of what's going on.
So now when you do this,
you do get a preview.
So it kind of like takes a quick
snapshot of the values
inside the object.
And so you can see kind
of at a glance.
So this becomes really useful,
especially when
you have a big object.
Let's grab window and
grab location.
And you can see very quickly
from a console log what some
of the properties on
this object are.
There's also another part of
this, which is that previously
the values here, when you logged
them out, they were
lazy evaluated.
So this ended up in a situation
where sometimes you
could log an object, change it,
log it again, and when you
went back to your console and
opened them back up, they
would be the same, which
you wouldn't expect.
So that essentially got fixed
with this change.
So you get both the preview and
that preview is evaluated
at log time instead of
at expansion time.
Does that makes sense, Addy?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
Yeah, it does.
PAUL IRISH: OK.
OK, good.
OK.
I think that's it for Console?
Yeah.
Do you want to show
a little bit?
I know that you made this cool
post on Google+ a little bit
ago about theming and skinning
your Chrome DevTools.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
So I was really surprised
at how much
people wanted this stuff.
It was like that's crazy.
We've got almost 1,000
shares on that.
It's insane.
So normally when you get a brand
new text editor, the
first thing a lot of time you do
is you go and try to find a
theme for it that you love,
because you're going to be
spending a lot of time in
your editor and you
want it to look great.
Sometime, like probably about a
year ago, a great developer
named Darcy Clarke figured out
that you can go and you can
actually customise the look
of the Chrome DevTools.
And I'm going to share my screen
for just a minute.
So this is Darcy's blog post
I'm going to be showing.
And he started this thread about
how you can go and you
can customize this, regardless
of what your
operating system is.
And there are so many
people that were
interested in this idea.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: So a year later,
I thought wouldn't it be
interesting to see where
people took this.
And so I put together this
post where I summarized a
bunch of the different themes
that people had worked on.
And it went crazy.
And there's probably 20, 30
themes available for the
DevTools these days.
Let's take a look
at one of them.
So this is a thing
called MNML.
PAUL IRISH: Ah-hum, hum.
ADDY OSMANI: It's building
up, MNML, MNML,
something like that.
But it's really cool.
You can actually customize
almost every single part of
the DevTools--
PAUL IRISH: That's hot.
ADDY OSMANI: --to look like
whatever you want.
There's some people who've like
gotten rid of the text
next to the icons.
And people have like bumped up
the size of the different
parts to it.
It's been really interesting.
PAUL IRISH: I would probably
apply like a WebKit transition
to a lot of things.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: And do some
3D transforms.
So instead of like switching
panels, like when you go from
Console to Elements, it
like does like a 3D,
phowswish, or something.
Let's put it out there.
I think it would be awesome.
ADDY OSMANI: What Paul is saying
is that right after
this, you can expect motherf'n
Chrome DevTools to come out.
PAUL IRISH: Ah.
Everyday.
ADDY OSMANI: That's
what he's saying.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: So on the back of
that post, there's this really
cool guy named Pascal Kremp
that started working on a
little gallery of DevTools
themes, which I thought was
cool, because like as much as
this stuff is up on GitHub
it's hard to find it.
And you need previews, you need
information about what
exactly it actually
customizes.
And so he put together this
website called devthemez, so
D-E-V-T-H-E-M-E-Z dot com.
And it just came out like this
week, but there are already
sort of theme authors that have
been sticking up their
themes on this.
And you can just like go into
any theme, take a preview of
some screenshots of it, go grab
the source and just apply
it to your DevTools.
And I thought it was
just kind of cool.
So, yeah, check it out.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
And I guess maybe we should
point out that the way that
this works is that
you're applying--
there's a bunch of CSS--
into your Chrome's
user stylesheet.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
PAUL IRISH: And it's just scoped
within the DevTools.
But it's just CSS that you're
applying in there.
And so you can do anything
you want.
You could probably use some of
those text shadows that we
showed earlier to really give
some umph to your tools.
ADDY OSMANI: Definitely.
PAUL IRISH: OK.
A little bit more inspection
stuff.
So I'm going to show
a few things.
So with Chrome DevTools now
there's new support for some
kind of emerging--
well, have-emerged features--
so Shadow DOM, IndexedDB,
and FileSystem.
So Shadow DOM is emerging.
It's a fundamental part of the
new web components spec.
And I'm really excited about,
wow, how it's going to affect
Web-Op development.
But, in fact, a lot of the
things that are already inside
the Chrome Developer Tools--
I'm sorry.
That's already inside of Chrome
and WebKit are built
with Shadow DOM.
So this is a video element.
I have some funny transforms
around it, just for fun, but
really we're just dealing with
a video element here.
I'm going to Inspect this.
Oh.
Come on.
I'm using a Command Shift C,
which is my favorite keyboard
shortcut for just diving right
into inspect mode immediately.
And if I open up the video
element, I do see my source
elements here, but I also
see Shadow-root.
And so this is pretty cool,
because we dive in through
these divs, and now you'll see
we have a button, an input
type range, a button range,
and so the actual UI--
this is the controls that
ship inside Chrome
for the video element--
this is just built with actual
elements with form controls.
The input type range actually
has Shadow DOM in it as well.
So it's just made out of divs.
So this is a Shadow DOM that
ships inside WebKit, but this
is available for everything.
You can turn it on the same way
that you saw Addy turn on
the SASS experiment earlier.
Now, let's see.
This is some IndexedDB.
So this is a little demo
application that uses IndexedDB.
And typically up until now there
hasn't been a good way
to see what's actually stored in
my IndexedDB inside Chrome.
So, as you can imagine,
now there is.
We dive into Resources, and
inside the application we just
have a bunch of items.
There are descriptions--
some and in a cart, some
are in a wish list.
And I'm going to add a tablet
into my wish list.
Cool?
And now when I come down
here, see my IndexedDB?
These are my data stores, one
of them, and wish list.
Here Is my tablet.
So it's just all my objects
that I have
stored inside my IndexedDB.
And it's available
to peruse here.
And I can also filter
right upside here.
The last one is FileSystem.
So the FileSystem API allows
you to save real files and
folders to the actual disk.
This is great for very large
files, but you can
use it with a lot.
So let's see.
With this little app, I
can create new folder.
Hello?
Awesome File TXT.
And while I'm at it, I'll also
drag in a JavaScript file.
And so this is just adding files
into my local FileSystem
store, this app.
And now I come over into
Resources, and we can see
what's actually stored here--
the folder that I made, the
image, the file, and then the
JavaScript and HTML that I
just dragged in.
So you immediately see what,
in fact, is stored there.
ADDY OSMANI: That's
really slick.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
It's hot.
So if you're using some of these
advanced features, we
want to make sure that we have
good developer support for you
to understand how this
is behaving.
So check those out.
Addy, should we mentioned a
little bit about what's going
on with Yeoman these days?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
Yeah.
Why not?
So Yeoman just shipped
a new version quite
recently, 0.9.4, I believe.
And we've got a lot of work
going on at the moment, trying
to work on Yeoman 1.0 and the
direction in which you want
the project to take.
So some of the things that we're
trying to look at doing
are upstreaming, some of the
different Yeoman tasks that
you guys are used to using,
some Grunt, so the broader
Grunt community can
start using those.
And we're trying to see what we
can do about making some of
our toolings, so things like
our scaffolding, better
available to broader parts
of the community.
So we're going to try making
sure that if you're a Grunt
user, a Yeoman user, you
can use those tools
more recently together.
And we're going to have some
more news about that stuff
coming up in a future show.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
Addy, let's do some questions?
ADDY OSMANI: Questions?
OK.
PAUL IRISH: We've got some
good ones that came in.
We'll take a few of them.
So let's see.
We haven't read through
this before, so we'll
just see how it goes.
ADDY OSMANI: No, we haven't.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
The latest version of
Safari ships with a
forked version of DevTools.
Does it mean that Apple is
no longer involved in the
development of standard WebKit
inspectors in collaboration
between Chrome-Safari teams
in this matter?
So, the way that it works is
that Inspector has a lot of
parts, and there's a back end
of Inspector that has the
instrumentation inside of
a WebKit, and then there
is the front end.
So Chrome DevTools, the front
end of Chrome DevTools is
actually upstreamed.
100% of it is actually present
in the WebKit.
And so that's what's there.
And Safari 6 went in a new
direction as far as its UI,
and I think it's pretty
cool to see.
And so the instrumentation
is still shared in the
background.
And there's still plenty of
collaboration between the teams.
New features that are coming
up, both teams are very
interested in making sure that
we can improve the developer
experience.
And so things are good.
You can just check out the
WebKit bug tracker.
All new features are tracked
there, and you can hop on and
see both teams working on
the same kind of stuff.
So, yes, it's good.
ADDY OSMANI: Cool.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
Jaruk asks--
ADDY OSMANI: A lot of these
are from Jaruk.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
PAUL IRISH: Jaruk asks
good questions.
Yeah, that's good.
Is it possible to observe in
real time which callbacks are
fired by DOM events?
I often forget to unsubscribe
from events that are no longer
needed, which causes them to
accumulate and slow down my
app with time.
[SIGH]
OK.
Yes.
So there's a few ways on this.
So if I look at Chrome
DevTools and
see if we get some--
Yeah, nice.
OK.
This is the Chrome DevTools
of these Inspector
questions that I have.
And I'm selecting the body
element right now here.
And we can see all event
listeners that are registered
for this element.
And we can click into them to
identify exactly where it's
coming from.
Like I have a Chrome extension
that's registering to click on
the document and then this
minified file that is also
digging into things.
So you can definitely
see what's bound.
And then if you want to go
a little bit deeper, for
instance, you can break
when event listeners
are about to be fired.
So let's say that I want
to identify on click
what's going on.
So let's see if I can do this.
Mouse, click.
Yeah.
Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: Nice.
PAUL IRISH: Very cool.
So now we're breaking and we're
actually breaking inside
of my event handler.
I'm going to [? predify ?]
this.
Hope it works.
There we go.
Cool.
All right.
So now we're actually broken
inside of the event handler
for this click, and
if I can just--
I can hit Play, and if there was
another event handler that
was bound to click for this
action, I would now be broken
inside of that.
So those are basically your two
good ways to get an idea
of what's still bound
for those elements.
ADDY OSMANI: I'll also add that
if you're having trouble
with sort of event listeners or
handlers that aren't being
unsubscribe so you're unbound,
you can also use our profiling
tools to find those pain points
in your application to
figure out where particular
amounts of memory are being
used and so on.
And we're going to try getting
out some better documentation
about that stuff soon.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
Can you share some plans for
DevTools related to a
responsive design?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
I don't mind showing something
about this.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
Go ahead.
ADDY OSMANI: I'm going
to share my
screen again very quickly.
Right.
So we briefly mentioned last
week the idea of--
if you go see Overrides panel,
so again if you've got
Experiments enabled, you get
all these options, but I do
believe most of these are
available and stable as well.
But if you go to the Settings
tog and you go to Overrides,
you can override a bunch of
stuff that will help you with
your responsive design workflow,
including things
like device metrics.
So if you wanted to go and
override your screen
resolution, if you wanted
to override your device
orientation, and so on, so you
can get a feel for the
different breakpoints in your
media query design flow, these
tools can help with that.
And if you go back to the
first episode of The
Breakpoint, we actually preview
some of this stuff.
But, yeah, there are definitely
some tools in there
that will help you with your
responsive design.
Do we have anything
more planned for
responsive design, Paul?
PAUL IRISH: That's a good
summary of things.
I will also point out that
normally the Chrome window, if
you're just resizing it for
funsies, it will max--
its midwidth will
be 400 pixels.
A lot of people want to
go down to below 360.
So if you just dock your
DevTools to the right using
the bottom-left icon--
ADDY OSMANI: Actually, Paul,
do you mind if I show that,
because we've been getting a
lot of questions on Stack
Overflow and its pitter lately
about how you properly dock
these days in Canary?
So we changed this recently.
So one thing you used to be able
to find was sort of how
to dock-to-right in
the settings.
But we've changed this
now to be an icon.
So I'm not sure if you
guys can see it.
I'll bump this up as
much as I can.
So in the left-hand corner, in
the bottom left-hand corner of
the DevTools, if you click and
hold on the Layout Manager
icon, it'll change the positions
of this stuff.
It's actually gone and it's
expanded in my case.
Oops.
PAUL IRISH: Oh-oh.
ADDY OSMANI: There we go.
PAUL IRISH: There you go.
ADDY OSMANI: So click
and hold.
So click and hold on that icon,
and you'll be able to
dock-to-right once again.
So, yup, it's slightly
different, but it still works.
Just the same.
PAUL IRISH: Yup.
So another improvement that just
landed is it'll remember
what your last date was, and so
you can just keep clicking
it to toggle between bottom
and right, for instance.
And we're also going to be--
I think it landed like
yesterday-- is--
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: --per
tab settings.
So let's say in one application
you really want to
see it, your DevTools, on the
bottom, and in the next tab
over you really want it
positioned on the right, and
now you can manage
that just fine.
ADDY OSMANI: Yup.
PAUL IRISH: But for responsive
design, what I was going to
say was that when it is docked
to right, you can just change
the split between your DevTools
and your page and
just bring it all the way down
to like 100 pixels wide.
So that helps a lot when you're
testing media queries,
for instance.
All right.
We'll do one last question.
This is also coming
in from Jaruk.
And he asks why support for
SASS and not just agnostic
[INAUDIBLE] processor support?
So right now SASS was chosen
first, just to kind of like
test things out, see that it
works, and also SASS already
had two different debug modes
where it outputted both line
numbers and a lot of debug
information, and Chrome
DevTools supports
both of those.
So you can compile SASS with
Enable Line Numbers, or I
think it's called Enable Debug
Info, and Chrome DevTools is
able to pick up the line number
mappings from that.
In the future, we would like
to see SASS output a proper
source map.
And so it can use Source
Map Version 3.
And that's like where things
will be going.
If you had LESS or Stylus and
are able to generate a source
map, then support for them
is really no problem.
And source maps are totally
language agnostic.
And so, yeah, I think that's
a summary there.
Oh.
One more thing.
So there's one last feature
inside Chrome DevTools that is
pretty new.
I wanted to show it.
And this is Styled
Console Messages.
ADDY OSMANI: Prepare to
have your mind blown.
PAUL IRISH: Shosh.
Wow.
OK.
Typically, your Console log,
it logs, it's good, but
sometimes you want a little
bit more pizazz, and
I don't blame you.
So if we take a look at how this
works, if I just paste in
these two guys, then--
Yeah.
Check that out.
ADDY OSMANI: Wow.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So Firebug has supported this
for a little bit of time.
And so we do a percent C, and
then we take the last argument
that's sent to log, and this
is just a bunch of CSS
that we send over.
And that just applies
into there.
ADDY OSMANI: And I can include
any CSS that I want in there.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
There's no--
I don't think there's
a blacklist or
a white list, so--
ADDY OSMANI: You can see where
we're going with this, right?
PAUL IRISH: All right.
So I'm going to bring up
one that I prepared
a little bit ago.
I have it over in my Snippets.
And so let's take a short
little message.
And instead of a background in
color, we're going to kind of
turn it up a little bit, add a
bit more CSS, and now we're
just going to use straight
up Console dot log.
Now, to send this to the
Console, I can just click this
Run icon down at the bottom.
Ah, yeah.
This is my Console.
It's pretty good looking.
You can do anything
you want here.
And I think it's really
important to
communicate with pizazz.
ADDY OSMANI: Gradients, with
gradients, is what he's
saying, with as many gradients
as possible.
PAUL IRISH: I like it.
All right.
I think that's it for this
episode of The Breakpoint.
ADDY OSMANI: That's it.
MODERATOR: We do have
some late-breaking
questions on YouTube.
PAUL IRISH: Oh, yeah?
MODERATOR: Yeah.
So what they want to know is
if you guys are allowing
developers to use Yeoman
with existing apps like
PAUL IRISH: Ah.
Good question.
Yup.
So we play this a little bit.
Addy, do you want
to tackle this?
ADDY OSMANI: Sure.
So we've had a lot of feedback
from developers in different
communities, from PHP, from
Rails, from [INAUDIBLE], and
everyone wants to be able to
use some sort of backend in
Yeoman, because if you're
building a web app, you're
going to have to have some sort
of backend that's for
data search, right, or just
being a server side processor?
Now, what we're going to be
doing in the coming months is
trying to improve your workflow
so that's it's easier
for you to hook into a different
backend, or hook
into a different
build process.
If you've already got sort of
an existing backend build
process for your Rudy app
or your Rails app, or
whathaveyou, this is something
that we're still working on at
the moment.
But there are people that are
sort of already hacking on
this with Yeoman, and we're
going to do our best to share
as much of that stuff as
possible on the Yeoman group.
But I think given another few
months, the Yeoman story with
other backends is going to
be much, much better.
PAUL IRISH: Yes.
You can google Yeoman PHP
and see an attempt by
Felix, Felix Gnass.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
PAUL IRISH: He wrote a little
bit of node middleware that
will pull in a PHP server
for the preview server.
The challenge here is that we
really want to be able to
still provide the LiveReload
functionality in the preview
environment, so we have the live
recompilation of SASS,
copy script, et cetera--
the LiveReload, so that the
iteration flow is really
solid, but we're still able
to host this using
your standard backend.
So we just want to make sure
that the way that this is
implemented scales extremely
well and still gives you that
sort of iteration workflow
that you want.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
And we want to do it right.
We realize that you guys have
got very different stacks all
over the place, and so we want
to do our best to make sure we
spur as much of the stuff as
possible if you guys want to
hack at it.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
All right.
I guess that will do it.
So thank you guys very
much for watching.
See you next time.
ADDY OSMANI: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]